>> Sean: YOU TOO HAVE A
GREAT SHOW AND RESULTS
PROBABLY MOMENTARILY.
>> Laura: GOOD NIGHT FROM
WASHINGTON.
THIS IS THE INGRAHAM ANGLE.
VOTERS ARE HEADED TO THE
POLLS TONIGHT FOR THE
SPECIAL ELECTION THAT PITTED
REPUBLICAN RICK SACCONE AND
DEMOCRAT CONOR LAMB AGAINST
EACH OTHER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP EASILY
DEFEATED HILLARY CLINTON
THERE IN 2016.
SO DEMOCRATS AND THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA HAVE TRIED
TO FRAME THE CONTEST AS A
BELLWETHER FOR A POTENTIAL
BLUE WAVE IN THE 2018 MID
TERMS.
IS THAT ACCURATE?
RIGHT NOW THE ELECTION IS
SIMPLY TOO CLOSE TO CALL.
AND JOINING US NOW WITH
REACTION FROM MIAMI IS
FORMER GOVERNOR OF THE GREAT
STATE OF PENNSYLVANIA, ED
RENDLE WHO IS PROBABLY VERY
HAPPY RIGHT NOW.
IS HE A DEMOCRAT.
IN NEW YORK MONICA CROWLEY
SENIOR FELLOW AT THE LONDON
CENTER FOR POLICY RESEARCH.
GOVERNOR RENDELL HAVE TO GO
TO YOU.
IF CONOR LAMB IN HIS EARLY
30'S, FORMER MILITARY MAN,
YOU KNOW, KIND OF A MODERATE
DEMOCRAT, HE PULLS OUT A
VICTORY, WHAT DOES IT SAY TO
YOU?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, IT IS
INDICATIVE OF WHAT'S GOING
ON ACROSS THE NATION.
THIS IS OUR 19TH SPECIAL
ELECTION.
AND EVERY ONE OF THEM THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE PICKED UP A
SUBSTANTIAL PERCENTAGE OF
THE VOTE FROM WHERE THEY
WERE IN '16.
THAT'S A GOOD SIGN FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
BUT UNDERSTAND, THE 18TH IS
GOOD TRUMP COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS A 51%
FAVORABLE RATING ACCORDING
TO THE MONMOUTH POLL IN THE
DISTRICT.
IT'S SOLID TRUMP COUNTRY.
LAMB TURNED OUT TO BE A
TERRIFIC CANDIDATE.
HE DID A GOOD JOB OF NOT
LETTING THE REPUBLICANS
NATIONALIZE THE RACE.
HE IS A MODERATE.
HE IS PRO-LIFE.
IS HE MODERATE ON GUNS.
HE IS VERY INTELLIGENT
CANDIDATE.
HE DID A GOOD JOB WITH THE
STEELWORKS AND THE COAL
MINERS.
GOT THEIR ENDORSEMENT.
IF HE WINS, AND IT'S STILL
CLOSE, I HAVE IT AT 700
VOTES WITH 36 PRECINCTS LEFT
TO BE CAST.
IF HE WINS IT, WILL BE A
CREDIT TO HIM.
>> Laura: THAT'S FOR SURE.
I WOULD TAKE ISSUE WITH THIS
IDEA IS HE PRO-LIFE.
THE NATIONAL REVIEW THIS
WEEK PUT THAT TO REST
BECAUSE IS HE NOT REALLY
PRO-LIFE.
HE SAYS WELL PERSONALLY.
>> IS HE MORE PRO-LIFE THAN
MOST DEMOCRATS.
>> Laura: YOU ARE RIGHT.
THAT'S RIGHT GOVERNOR
RENDELL, IS HE NOT A NANCY
PELOSI DEMOCRAT.
SO, MONICA, WHAT DOES THIS
SAY TO THE DEMOCRAT PARTY
THOUGH IF THIS IS THE TYPE
OF DEMOCRAT WHO CAN WIN IN A
DISTRICT WHERE TRUMP WON,
WHAT DOES THAT SAY TO THE
PELOSI, SCHUMER WING OF THE
PARTY?
THEY ARE MOVING LEFT AND
CONOR LAMB SEEMED TO MOVE TO
THE RIGHT.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT,
LAURA.
THE CURRENT DEMOCRATIC PARTY
IS BARACK OBAMA'S DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
IT'S NO LONGER BILL
CLINTON'S DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
A PARTY PRAGMATISTS AND
CENTRIST.
IT IS A FAR LEFT RADICAL
PARTY.
CONOR LAMB BROKE THE MOLD
FROM THAT BECAUSE HE WAS
RUNNING IN A DISTRICT THAT
DONALD TRUMP WON BY 20
POINTS.
VERY CONSERVATIVE DISTRICT.
SO THIS IS A YOUNG MARINE
VETERAN WHO AS THE GOVERNOR
SAID HAD A SERIES OF VERY
CONSERVATIVE POSITIONS ON
GUNS AND OTHER ISSUES THAT
HE EMBRACED IN ORDER TO TRY
TO WIN THIS RACE.
THE LESSON GOING FORWARD
THEN FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IS IF YOU WANT TO TRY
TO GET BACK TO AN APPEAL TO
THE WORKING CLASS VOTERS,
THAT HELPS PUT DONALD TRUMP
OVER THE TOP, PARTICULARLY,
LAURA, IN THOSE TEN KEY
SWING STATES LIKE
PENNSYLVANIA, OHIO,
MICHIGAN, WISCONSIN, THEN
YOU BETTER CHANGE YOUR TUNE
AND GET BACK TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PRINCIPLES OF THE
PARTY OF OLD, WHICH IS MORE
PRAGMATIST, CENTRIST, AND
MODERATE AND REJECT THE
PELOSI AND BARACK OBAMA FAR
LEFT KIND OF RADICAL
APPROACH.
>> Laura: GOVERNOR RENDELL,
I SAID THIS FOR SOME TIME
AND OTHERS HAVE AS WELL,
THAT'S WHERE THE DEMOCRATS'
SWEET SPOT ALWAYS WAS, THE
PARTY OF THE LITTLE GUY.
AND SOMEHOW THE DEMOCRATS
BECAME THE PARTY OF LIKE THE
TEACHER'S UNIONS, OF THE
TRIAL LAWYERS, OF THE
PLANNED PARENTHOOD, AND I
THINK THEY MISSED JUST LIKE
THE REPUBLICANS DID IN A
DIFFERENT WAY, THEY MISSED
THE HEART OF AMERICA.
AND THE HEART OF AMERICA
RUNS RIGHT THROUGH
PENNSYLVANIA.
RIGHT THROUGH PENNSYLVANIA.
>> NO QUESTION YOU ARE
RIGHT.
THE CORE VALUES OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY GOING BACK
50 YEARS ARE VALUES MOST
AMERICANS AGREE WITH WE HAVE
GOTTEN AWAY INTEREST THEM.
WE PLAY IDENTITY POLITICS.
IT ISN'T GOOD.
I TELL MY PROGRESSIVE
FRIENDS.
I SAID CONOR LAMB WILL CAST
A VERY IMPORTANT VOTE AND
THE VOTE THAT YOU SHOULD
CARE MOST ABOUT.
AND THAT'S FOR THE NEXT
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
WHETHER IT'S NANCY PELOSI OR
SOMEBODY ELSE.
IF IT'S A DEMOCRAT, WE CAN
BRING LEGISLATION TO THE
FLOOR THAT WE CAN'T GET TO
THE FLOOR NOW.
THAT'S THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT THING.
AND IF WE WANT TO BE A PARTY
THAT REALLY CONTROLS, WE
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT IN
OUR PROGRESSIVE WING HAS TO
UNDERSTAND IT MOST OF ALL.
>> Laura: YOU THINK OF THE
ALARMISM OVER TRUMP'S
TERRORISTS, FOR INSTANCE,
AND BOTH SACCONE AND LAMB
GAVE FAIRLY DECENT SUPPORT
FOR THE IDEA OF TARIFFS.
IT'S NOT AS BROAD BASED AS
TRUMP.
THEN YOU THINK OF THE CATER
WALLING WE HEARD FROM BOTH
THE ESTABLISHMENT DEMOCRAT
SOME OF THEM AND
ESTABLISHMENT REPUBLICANS,
MORE SO THE REPUBLICANS, IT
JUST SHOWS YOU THIS IS WHY
TRUMP WON IN PENNSYLVANIA
BECAUSE HE IS FOR BRINGING
BACK MANUFACTURING THAT BOTH
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS,
OBAMA AND HILLARY AND
REPUBLICANS HAD SAID WERE
NEVER GOING TO GET THOSE
JOBS BACK.
THAT WAS AN INSULT TO THE
VOTERS OF PENNSYLVANIA,
OHIO, WISCONSIN, IOWA, AND
BEYOND.
AND SO IF I'M A DEMOCRAT
WATCHING THIS TONIGHT, I
DON'T CARE IF YOU ARE LIVING
IN CALIFORNIA OR LIVING IN
WISCONSIN OR OHIO, CONOR
LAMB, IF HE PULLS OUT THIS
NARROW VICTORY, THEY HAVE
GOT TO LOOK AT THIS AND SAY,
WAIT A SECOND, WE BETTER
EXAMINE WHERE WE ARE IN A
WHOLE HOST OF ISSUES.
I KNOW THE COUNTRY IS
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT PLACES.
THAT WAS TRUMP'S RECIPE FOR
SUCCESS AND IT CAN BE THE
DEMOCRATS' RECIPE FOR
SUCCESS.
>> REMEMBER, LAURA, DONALD
TRUMP CIRCUMSTANTIAL CREATED
A NEW
CRNEW
CREAW
CREATE -- ESSENTIALLY A NEW
WINNING COALITION.
DONALD TRUMP TURNED
EVERYTHING UPSIDE DOWN.
HE ESSENTIALLY WAS THE FIRST